I think the, the most important thing that, that inspired me to start to
shoot Keep In Mind is that they they should have a very curious mind.
>> Mm-hm.
>> They should have the ability to ask questions, to kind of formulate these
questions as it pertains to them, as, as they would see these questions being
raised in their own lives. So if, if there's a problem they see with
the, with the, with the pieces that they are working with or with again
with the project that they're working with, they should, they
should try to they should try to ask these questions in
terms of and how they can understand for themselves. And
once they understand, once they know what is the, the, the
gist of the question is, then they can go and
use algorithms. Obviously it helps tremendously if you know, if you
have experience about all the arguments that are out there
to attack these questions. But I think the most important ability
that, that you should have as a data scientist, and you,
you could obviously improve throughout your, your career in this is
that you have this this inquisitive mindset, where, where you are
trying to ask the right questions while you are trying to, to
see what is important. And you also have an overview of
what kind of data can support in the end, your conclusions
that you are going to draw draw with the help of
these algorithms that you are going to use to solve these problems.